every single time you guys kill somebody
i'll give you a thousand dollars i like
killing
a thousand dollars oh we should go we
should go i'm going
and thank you world company for
sponsoring this video
hey thanks for the free thousand dollars
bro
they're all right here where's right
here oh they're all right here
got one oh you're bad kid you're bad
ah no no no no your aim's trash
i'm top fragging and this
is probably the perfect time to mention
that only the person with the most kills
gets a thousand dollars per kill
what what dude i just gotten gays i want
to win for my wedding
if you get it down and somebody else
gets the kill then you guys both get it
i got one
jimmy you're doing really good but we
don't need you to do good right now
no with this stupid reloading thing guys
let's standardize come on
let's go b they won't expect us to go b
every time
oh my god ah you have aimbot i'm
planning the ball mommy
why i'm listening
that's not quiet shut up i can't hear
zero pressure for you to fail i believe
in you
don't miss those shots jimmy oh that's
right
that guy literally didn't hit a single
shot on jimmy all right
everyone go b unless you hate your mom
and i don't know if i told you guys but
we're actually playing
three games this is just the first one
all right let's go chris tryhard mode
activated
oh what
[Music]
tickling your butt chandler has 17 kills
holy
crap that's a lot of money chandler carl
and chris if you guys win you're
stealing money from chandler's wedding
good whoa that'd be awesome you're not
invited if you steal
got him oh death boom got me nice
you did it i did it i did it i killed
death boom
i'm not out of this yet i can do it oh i
got one of them
i got another one wow i'm
freaking dirty chandler has so far made
21 thousand dollars and this is just the
first game
you guys suck i killed death bloom
i might full sweep i might full sweep
this yeah carl
oh he just finished planting the boat
nice you know if you didn't defuse that
bomb you would have got another round
chandler's in the league with 21 kills
let me thank carl then chris
i can do it all right let's rush hey
guys i just have a sword
the sword doesn't do any damage
he's down oh shoot
hey i still got the kill i still got to
kill him
all right i got one kill i gotta step it
up
got one
holy cow i just got so many kills
oh god save me
chris don't worry save me right here
they left they left you're good you're
good
i hate you thank you chris
i don't even want to play anymore
yo i got one oh i'm me on me
wow of course again behind me carl where
the heck are you i got a kill
i play games hello
behind you oh i just got so many kills
since you two are so far ahead of chris
for this round you can only use your
pistols
okay all right fine whatever
i still got it
i'm behind us no oh no jailer i tried to
revive you we just got executed
i still got it
there we go three kills with the pistol
i don't know how to stop carl's three
kills ahead of you now chandler i can
still come back from this
on your left good call out
[Music]
jimmy's aim's bad oh oh okay we're just
gonna act like that dude
hey carl is four kills ahead
dude holy cow i'm gonna make so much
money i gotta step up my game
if you let me win jimmy it'll make it
cheaper somehow
oh three oh there's a fourth one
there he is dude i went stupid right
there yeah they are bad
they quit their whole team just rage
quit and it's now time for the third
and final game carl is in the lead by
one kill
30 plus thousand dollars is on the line
let's see who gets it
i think i can come back oh on me i'm in
turn around chandler help help
hey one on me one's on me
i got two grand that round chanter is
now two behind
i can do this go b
right got him one more chris right there
on the wall on the wall
yes sir easy easy easy i can do it i can
do it and i know what you guys are
thinking how can i play this amazing
game that you guys are playing right now
it's called rogue company and it's
available on the epic game store and now
steam
what and on top of that they just
released a brand new 6v6 game mode so
you can play with even more people
if you use our link in description to
install rogue company on steam you get
the season 2 battle pass for free that's
an insane deal
and carl you want to know the best part
about this game what's the best part
about this game it's literally cross
platform
wait actually and cross progression
cross progression that's even better
i died if you link your account with
epic games xbox live
and or playstation live you can
literally play with any of your friends
at all times wait that's sick
so if you haven't already click the link
description download rogue company on
steam and go play with all your friends
it's genuinely so much fun
i'm having a blast oh mommy
i got kills because you are behind by
like
a dozen kills this is my only chance
carl you're three ahead of chandra
got him chandler you're six kills behind
you need to go clutch mode
i didn't see anyone that round
i got two of them
see ya wait wait carl wait hold on
really yes
carl you're not doing so hot this game
carl for this round i need you to use
your pistol
all right let's go
oh my god i got killed i got killed
oh yay we lost a round we lost yes
we lost oh that means there's another
round wait now i have to pistol round
again
if you don't use a katana you're bad i'm
a ninja
i hit somebody with it
let's go carl's up by one kill chandler
are you clutch i'm still up by one kill
holy cow
carl versus chandler who is the better
gamer me
i don't know i'm better in my mind
[Music]
no way i died please pick me up
no
yes he won by two kills carl came in
first place with 48 kills which means he
wins
48 000 yes
carl here's the twist i didn't mention
at the beginning you have to give it
away to someone you can give it to
anyone
who do you want to give it to listen i
just wanted to beat him but i'm gonna
give it to chandler because he's about
to have a wedding yes
thank you so much i'm proud of you jayla
if you're really happy you should kiss
him